salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans questions aux sénateurs
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
d'acropolis et public sénat
dans lequel on reçoit un sénateur une
sénatrice qui répond à toutes vos
questions cette semaine on a le plaisir
d'accueillir jean marie bockel
bonjour bonjour jean marie bockel vous
êtes sénateur centriste du haut rhin on
va passer une heure ensemble et
apprendre à vous connaître et discuter
de l'actualité
votre actualité et celle du sénat et
surtout bonjour à vous c'est vous qui
allez faire cette émission bonjour à
vous si vous nous regardez actuellement
en direct sur twitter bonjour à vous si
vous nous regardez en replay sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt et bonjour à
vous si vous nous écoutez aussi en
podcast je voudrais qu'on commence avec
vous on va faire votre portrait on va
apprendre à vous connaître mais je
voudrais quand même qu'on commence par
l'actualité brûlante l'actualité chaude
ce qui se passe actuellement aux etats
unis
on est maintenant dix jours après le
meurtre de deux genres floyd vous l'avez
vu la vidéo du meurtre de george clooney
bien sûr puisqu'elle passe en boucle et
tout le monde l'a vu et tout le monde a
été et ce que vous avez ressenti vous
quand vous l'avez vu j'étais révulsés il
n'y a pas de mot assez fort enfin c'est
épouvantable quelqu'un qui meurt en
direct qui appellent au secours qui
n'est pas entendue en fin ou c c'est le
pire qu'on puisse imaginer quoi
manifestation monstre partout aux états
unis à la foulée de cette alors ses
idéaux
c'est l'amérique quand même c'est à dire
quoi c'est l'amérique
ça veut dire que
[Musique]
sur ma réponse n'est pas de relativiser
ce qui s'est passé puisque je viens de
vous dire
recent mai
pour comprendre comprendre afin de enfin
que ça cesse quoi il faut avoir à
l'esprit cette part de la mentalité
africaine de la mentalité afro
américains d'où mon lapsus de la
mentalité américaine vis-à-vis des qui
ne relève wii qui ne relève pas que par
exemple de comportement individuel et
d'evian je veux dire par exemple si
certains font la comparaison avec la
france il ya même eu une manif d'hier on
va en parler ça amène à parler mais si
vous voulez je ne dirais pas la même
chose s'agissant de la france
soyez de la réalité française la réalité
américaine c'est l'histoire de l'éclat
de l' esclavage c'est encore dans la
deuxième moitié du xxème siècle inde et
forme d'apartheid qui n'ont pas
complètement disparu
ça a été une évolution de la société par
rapport à cette question du racisme de
la discrimination qui par delà les lois
et dans certains états évidemment plus
que dans d'autres a été extrêmement
lente chaotique n'est pas terminée avec
derrière en parallèle dans ce pays
richissime la question sociale 1 et de
la pauvreté et tout ce qui va avec tous
les maux qui peuvent aller avec et qui
touche hier la communauté noire
essentiellement aujourd'hui aussi pour
reprendre le vocabulaire américain on
parle de communauté la communauté
hispanique 1 mais toujours la communauté
noire
donc ça si vous voulez c'est une réalité
c'est les paradoxes américains parce que
on a eu un président des états unis noir
on a eu quelques années avant un chef
d'état major des armées
colin powell noir une secrétaire d'état
c'est à dire la femme politique la plus
importante après le président dans
l'organisation américaine
noir etc donc il ya eu aussi bien sur
une évolution au niveau de la promotion
sociale de la place des noirs dans la
société dans la police vous allez
regarder la police de los angeles
il ya beaucoup de noirs dans la police
c'est ça le paradoxe américain c'est à
dire que il y a eu des évolutions
considérables mais il y a encore cette
réalité alors évidemment je ne ramène
pas tous au sociologique
il ya aussi des comportements
individuels raciste on voit bien que 1
il n'y a pas une explication seulement
sociologique de ces images c'est un
comportement individuel inadmissible et
criminel mais il ya quand même une toile
de fond que nous devons avoir à l'esprit
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est ça
l'amérique alors mais justement vous
avez l'air de faire un distinguo profond
entre l'amérique et la france et pour
vous il n'ya pas de mimétisme je fais
pas je vais pas un distinguo profond
parce que les sociétés occidentales à
bien des égards se ressemblent et on dit
souvent que les pays européens dont la
france
suivent quelques années après et pas que
pour le meilleur parfois pour le
meilleur une forme de modernité parfois
aussi pour le moins bon le pire les
états unis mais c'est un peu trop facile
de se contenter de dire ça si vous
voulez la réalité française bon vous
n'avez pas encore raconter un peu mon
histoire mon a encore mais juste pour
vous dire d'où je parle pour moi j'étais
maire pendant plus de vingt ans pendant
21 ans d'une ville qui s'appelle
mulhouse en alsace où nous avons et nous
avions déjà quand j'étais maire je suis
plus maire depuis dix ans mais c'est pas
si vieux nous avions 120 nationalités et
donc tout toutes les questions de de
violence de racisme discrimination
2 2 enfin tous ces mots je les connais
mais je trouve quand même que bien sûr
nous nous avons l'histoire du
colonialisme exactement essais des
réflexions qui sont faites dans le chat
depuis tout à l'heure nous avons une
histoire du colonialisme mais on ne peut
pas non plus
soixante ans après la décolonisation
dans la république française où tout de
même tout le monde met son point
d'honneur au niveau des gouvernements
qui se sont succédé et de toute tendance
politique droite gauche à appliquer
certains principes et alors il ya des
dérapages
ben justement mais d'où la maison est ce
que c'est parce qu'il ya aussi un
système en france raciste
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient un système
consiste en france je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient un racisme systémique en
france je pense d'ailleurs que les
français et je vous le dis vraiment
profondément comme je le pense son en
tant que que société française peu
raciste peut il y a beaucoup de raciste
il y en a d'ailleurs partout 1
mais dire que la france est un pays
profondément raciste comme certains le
disent
à l'instar de certains autres pays dans
une certaine mesure des états unis même
si tout le monde n'est pas raciste aux
états unis heureusement nouveau ce n'est
pas ce n'est de mon point de vue pas
vrai et d'ailleurs et dire ça et
procéder à de tels amalgames et tout
mettre sur le dos du racisme
à mon avis n'est pas le bon moyen
d'améliorer les choses
il faut être comme le disait encore le
miz l'intérieur que nous interrogions
que nous interpellions au sénat cet
après midi 1 sans faille par rapport à
des comportements lui parle évidemment
de la police mais il n'ya pas que la
police mais il est mise de l'intérieur
raciste il ya des condamnations
on ne laisse rien passer un bon il peut
y avoir des erreurs aussi il peut y
avoir aussi bien sur le musicien n'est
pas parfait mais tout de même ça ne veut
pas dire que il y a donc on peut
généraliser
par contre chaque comportement raciste
et compris au niveau de gens qui ont des
fonctions d'autorité police ou autre est
un comportement raciste de trop 20 ne
doit pas laisser passer 20
manifestants hier vingt mille personnes
qui ont bravé l'interdiction de
manifester pour dénoncer les violences
policières dans le cadre de la sphère
traoré enfin une personne qui dénonce la
violence policière et le racisme dans la
police oui on a encore plein de redire
dans la police d'en simuler
moi je ne suis pas là pour exprimer à la
place des gens quand il ya vingt mille
personnes qui manifestent
chacun a quelque chose d exprimer
il y a une expression de refus et de
rejet du racisme
il ya aussi une expression sûrement
et ce n'était pas exactement la même
chose de refus de toute forme de
discrimination qu'on peut vivre c'est ce
n'est pas exactement la même chose il ya
des gens qui discrimine sans être
raciste parce que tout simplement ils
ont le sentiment de mon point de vue à
tort que ça leur posera un problème
d'embolisation la police le contrôle au
faciès les violences particulières dans
les banlieues etc
c'est oui je pense qu'il ya ça mais je
voulais je pense qu'il n'ya pas que ça
je pense que il ya aussi la question
sociale
je pense qu'il ya aussi la peur de
l'avenir
je pense qu'il ya aussi disons le
crûment
le semi échec du modèle d'intégration à
la française dit semi échec parce que si
souvent avec une forme d'humour
pendant les travaux les ventes
continuent c'est à dire que pendant que
on est en échec sur un certain nombre de
de politique d'intégration etc
il ya quand même beaucoup de réussite en
même temps mais mais mais il ya une
difficulté mais il ya un problème et ça
si vous voulez ça crée aussi un des
crispations des frustrations des
révoltes et tout ça ça s'exprime ses
principes de l'étincelle
tous expriment en même temps qu'il y est
ce que vous dites au niveau du contrôle
des contrôles d'identité à répétition
etc
c'est certainement quelque chose qui est
aussi exprimé dans ces manifestations
mais derrière ça il ya aussi
si vous les mettez vous un instant parce
que les français sont paradoxaux il n'y
a pas que moi qui le suis à la fois on
est prompt à montrer du doigt
l'institution policière à travers un
certain nombre de contre exemple qui
existe et en même temps on est tous les
soirs dans les séries policières dans
des films policiers
1 et c'est parce que est où là sa droite
ça n'empêche pas ce que je suis pas j'ai
pas dis que c'est empêcher là on voit la
société
à laquelle les forces de l'ordre quelles
qu'elles soient sont confrontés qui est
une société qui est plus violente
qu'elle n'est qu'elle n'était qui est
plus injuste qu'elle n'était qui est
confronté à des problèmes d'éducation
d'insertion de famille avec une
structure familiale qui a éclaté de
drogue etc
donc je veux dire il faut aussi quand
vous écoutez par exemple des
représentants de la police syndicats
même des syndicats progressiste hoyé pas
mal et on ne pense pas des gens qui sont
dans les extrêmes
ils traduisent aussi un ras-le-bol
traduit deux ils sont les premiers à
dire nous on est des républicains nous
on est anti raciste nous on trouve que
le métier qu'on fait c'est terrible
parce que se concentre sur nous qui
sommes en première ligne
certains enseignants le disent aussi
certains autres services publics même de
santé d'hôpitaux le disent aussi se
concentre sur nous toutes les tensions
de cette société alors je vois là je
pense que je pourrais vous tenir un
discours simple et voilà c'est sûr y'a
qu'ça s'passe normal on est on est tous
des racistes
voilà mon devoir enfin ma responsabilité
de l'homme politique c'est aussi
d'essayer à partir du vécu de
l'expérience n'ont pas de m'éloigner de
planer dans la stratosphère
mais d'ici et à une analyse du pourquoi
de manière à ce que ça te donne des
armes pour que ça aille mieux demain on
va parler de vous jean marie bockel on
va parler de vous on va parler de votre
parcours vous êtes juriste études de
droit puis avocat à mulhouse
mais avant ça vous êtes rentré en
politique à une époque un peu
particulière ces thèmes avocat j'étais
avocat de la ligue des droits de l'homme
j'étais avocats des syndicats j'ai été
avocat d'objecteur de conscience bientôt
officier de réserve enfin voila j'ai je
vivais mes contradictions déjà pardon je
vous aime tous mais non mais non mais
justement il justement vous parlez vous
même justement de cet engagement de
notre engagement il a commencé tôt
c'était mai 68 ces vielles 18 ans en mai
68 racontez nous un peu cette période là
parce que nous ceux qui ont 18 ans
aujourd'hui qui nous écoutent quand vous
l'avez vécu à acheter en gt j'avais 18
ans je me passionnait déjà pour la
politique c'était l'époque du général de
gaulle
j'étais en terminale je vous ai fait
quel côté alors parce que les bains sous
les dans mon lycée de la petite ville de
thann en alsace où j'avais je faisais ma
scolarité où j'habitais c'est moi avec
un ou deux camarades qui avons été au
point de départ à l'origine un des
manifestations que nous avons fait dans
les rues
enfin et disons d'une participation à ce
mouvement à l'époque quoi qui qui nous
parlaient un qui nous disait quelque
chose quoi et et qu'on trouvait en plus
passionnant quoi du point de vue des
idées qui étaient échangés et c'est
alors que nous étions loin du quartier
latin
nous étions loin des pavés des violences
et de tout ce que l'on voyait déjà à
l'époque à la télévision mais oui on
s'est senti concerné et c'était mon
premier engagement politique
est ce que vous voyez un mimétisme avec
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui les jeunes
aujourd'hui de 18 ans qui se mobilisent
dans le cadre de la de la lutte contre
la loi travail de nuit debout des gilets
jaunes et cetera
cette envie et ce besoin de révolte que
vous avez ressenti à 18 à 18 ans est ce
que vous comprenez que les jeunes
aujourd'hui divisant le ressentent aussi
bien sûr que je le comprends d'ailleurs
le fait de m'être engagé très tôt
pas forcément
prévu dans mon milieu familial plutôt
bas de la bourgeoisie de province un
n'était pas le sentry à chichis ma
famille mon père mon grand père faisait
de la politique il était engagé
centriste donc du coup moi je me suis
engagé évidemment pas du coup quelques
d'accord c'est le fils et le petit-fils
à gauche dans une famille plutôt oui non
mais ma famille j'étais très diverses et
un politiquement on parlait tout le
temps de politique
mon père et ma mère votez pas de la même
manière c'était assez drôle mais j'ai eu
du coup la culture du débat
mais plus sérieusement le fait d'avoir
été engagé et d'avoir été engagés au
départ dans une démarche bas de de
révolte de contestation de remise en
cause de la société qui a porté du bon
et du moins bon mais c'était quand même
mon engagement de l'époque m'amène j'ai
moi même des enfants et même les petits
enfants mais je ne pourrais pas ne pas
être tolérant quoi et je ne pourrai pas
me comporter simplement comme
un vieux con réactionnaire quoi enfin je
vais devoir de me rappeler
même si après on change on évolue
évidemment et tout le monde évolue
heureusement d'ailleurs un coup qu'on
évolue et ça veut pas dire pour autant
que je me sens sympathie avec tous les
tous les mouvements 1 qui foisonnent
aujourd'hui en france et notamment de
contestation radicale parce que je suis
arrivé à un moment de ma vie de mon
expérience où je pense que même quand on
est dans la remise en cause dans la
critique il faut être porteur c'est en
tout cas les jeunes de 18 ans qui
aujourd'hui sommeil les extinctions l'a
déjà je prête je préfère que des jeunes
s'engagent way à ce qu'ils ne s'engagent
pas alors à propos d' engagement vous
adhérer au parti socialiste en 1973 il
était très différent du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui 173 céder quoi l'ambiance à
l'époque
écoutez c'était c'était une d'abord
comme beaucoup de partis politiques mais
peut-être le parti socialiste plus que
d'autres partis c'était vraiment une
école de la démocratie de la politique
dans ce qu'elles avaient de meilleur
le débat d'idées et au parti socialiste
mais sont très divisés quand j'étais à
l'époque dans le courant de jean pierre
chevènement
il y avait hier au gardien élevé des
mitterrandistes en plus entre enfin et
c'était un débat d'idées qui à travers
les congrès et réguliers étaient
connectés sur l'exercice du pouvoir dans
le parti c'est à dire que à chaque
congrès c'est au tour de deux textes qui
donnait une ligne politique que se
déterminer ce qui a des gouvernés le
parti
donc il y avait un lien direct entre les
idées la confrontation d'idées et
ensuite les orientations qui ont donné
au parti
donc c'était à la fois comment vous dire
c'était de la bagarre permanente
et aussi à bien des égards
maternelle nous c'est dans une fratrie
je suis l'aîné de sept et j'ai cinq
enfants dans une fratrie on se dispute
mais ça reste une fratrie donc c'était
la bagarre
la confrontation parfois même de
l'incantation ou du sectarisme les uns
par rapport aux autres et fraternelle et
c'était une école de la responsabilité
parce que dans un parti on prend des
responsabilités
ensuite on se présente à des élections
c'était une sorte d'université c'est à
dire un endroit on se forme en
permanence et quand je vois moi regardez
par exemple en marche quand je vois
arriver je dis pas tout je veux pas
caricaturer d'un certain nombre de
nouveaux élus qu'ils soient avec la
bienveillance avec eux voilà le vieux
monde c'est terminé et cetera d'emblée
je suis bon on va peut-être c'est vrai
quoi
mais on a dû très vite en réalité que
c'était à certains égards au niveau des
comportements au niveau tpir même nom
mais nous nous avions quand même alors
je dis pas qu'on est meilleur c'est pas
du tout ça
george clooney en mai nous avions cet
apprentissage pour moi ça a été précieux
parce que évidemment j'ai été député
très tôt vous le dis à 30 ans à 30 ans à
30 ans j'avais 10 ans d'expérience
politique
vous avez rappelé mai 68 après j'ai
quand même essayé de faire mes études
sérieusement c'est mon père me dit et
fais ce que tu veux mais faut que tu es
un métier parce que c'était pas un
métier n'était pas indépendant il
n'avait pas tort donc j'ai eu un
engagement syndical étudiant syndicale
dans un syndicat c'est pas l'unef
c'était un syndicat qui s'appelait le
marx était à 5 approche de la cfdt
d'accord voyez c'était un peu la
mouvance chrétiens de gauche et ensuite
j'ai adhéré au parti socialiste j'avais
22 23 ans 1
et j'ai eu huit ans si vous en avez dans
tissage si vous enlevez l'année de
service militaire ou faisait de la
politique aussi d'apprentissage
politique à travers des congrès à
travers des candidatures à des élections
ou ne gagnait pas donc quand j'ai été
député à 30 ans j'avais 10 ans de
formation politique
ça m'a beaucoup servi vous êtes devenu
député à 30 ans et surtout
ministre un ministre très rapidement à
30 81 34 ans ministre très jeunes de
françois mitterrand adam gouvernement de
pierre mauroy en l'occurrence secrétaire
non c'était juste après pierre mauroy
424,7 et laurent fabius
j'étais gouvernement dans la période ça
du secrétaire d'état au commerce à
l'artisanat et au tourisme puis j'ai
remplacé crépeau à la fin communiste du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
c'était comme ça cela s'appelait à
l'époque les ministères maintenant les
noms un peu changé mais c'est d'ailleurs
dommage qu'il y ait plus ministre de
l'artisanat et du tourisme pour faire ça
c'est une autre question est
effectivement oui donc ministre dans un
gouvernement dans un gouvernement
socialiste socialiste un moment le
communiste n'était plus là quoi manger
socialiste de l'homogène quoi
chevènementiste jusqu'au début des
années 90 oui tout à fait il toujours
amis de jean pierre chevènement est
toujours admirateur de jean pierre
chevènement
j'ai souvent fois pierre chevènement
c'est quelqu'un alors même quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec lui il faut
argumenter et c'est cet exigeant de ne
pas être d'accord avec jean pierre et en
plus il m'arrive assez souvent d'accord
avec lui on a eu des divergences sur
l'europe parce que manger comme alsacien
j'étais très européen mais on a eu quand
même
enfin il maïmat il m'a énormément appris
j'ai énormément de respect pour jean
pierre chevènement s'était à l'époque
pour moi il y a
temps 47 ans un homme d'état déjà c'est
pour moi aujourd'hui toujours un homme
d'état pardon non mais continuons
justement être avec jean pierre
chevènement à cette époque là c'est le
crs c'est plutôt la gauche du parti
socialiste éclairé corps et puis voilà
les années 90 vous devenez enfants vous
devenez ou pas d'ailleurs mais
réformateurs au sein du parti socialiste
je deviens de l'eau rien c'est à dire eh
ben c'est à dire que c'est plutôt le si
voulez j'ai été fidèle à jean pierre
moi je suis un homme de fidélité g j'ai
évolué mais si vous voulez j'étais 18
ans 18 ans de mon engagement politique
proche de jean-pierre on se le rappeler
encore l'autre jour et forcément on est
d accord
et moi j'avais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
certains égards déjà je me suis fourvoyé
dans mon espérance européenne parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est tous un peu déçus
de ce qu'est devenue l'europe mais je
reste quand même un militant européen
jeu l'était et à l'époque c'est jacques
delors un qui était à la fois le
commissaire européen français
emblématique un des pères de l'europe de
l'époque mitterrand kohl et en même
temps quelqu'un qui était assez fidèle
au parti socialiste et qui avait donc
avec des gens comme comme martine aubry
sa fille comme françois hollande 1 qui
était quand même à l'époque un
moderniste et un européen vraiment et
quelques autres animés eu un courant de
lorient européens et comme on disait à
l'époque social libéral
bon il ya eu aussi strauss-kahn qui
était pas loin même s'il n'était pas
directement ça qu'on appelle les règles
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on appellerait la
droite du parti
oui mais à l'époque on disait déjà ça de
l'or mais voilà bien aimé se balancer
des invectives donc à cibler mais pour
moi c'était un peu c'était logique ça
correspondait à mon inspiration
européenne
ensuite si vous voulez je me suis entre
guillemets droitisée
en me rapprochant de l'idéal blairiste
puisque quelques années plus tard 97
je m'étais intéressé à blair déjà un peu
avant parce que l'époque jospin je
n'étais pas du tout à l'aise non pas
avec les grandes qualités de jospin qui
est à certains égards un homme du
gouvernement de bon niveau mais il y
avait une contradiction entre un
discours assez à gauche voire très à
gauche
intransigeant et des actes qui étaient
du libéralisme sans dire et pour moi les
privatisations ça n'allait pas du tout
quoi d'accord et donc je veux si je me
suis dit à l'époque mais vous savez on
juge souvent avec les yeux d'aujourd'hui
une époque qui a maintenant plus de 20
ans si je dis j'étais blairiste social
libéral évidemment certains de vos
auditeurs disent je peux pas vous parler
en même temps regarder le chat qui
passent à toute vitesse mais moi je le
vois qu'elle a fallu blairiste on voit
on voit bien ce que ça a donné
faut se mettre dans le contexte de
l'époque séoul et la recherche d'un
équilibre 1 entre une dimension sociale
que je percevais déjà j'étais déjà maire
de mulhouse et l'idée quand même que
sans l'économie on ne fait rien et que
si on veut réguler l'économie faut que
ces économies elles existent cependant
la tuant que la réguler rats bon partir
de là évidemment
là j'ai été utilisé au sein du ps
au fond ça arrangeait tout le monde
comme le droitier que celui qui me
montrait du doigt n'était pas par
définition donc gg
j'ai joué sur les mots crise
immédiatement ce n'était pas très
agréable mais j'imagine bon vous êtes
allé au bout du chemin si je puis dire
parce que voilà vous avez fini par
quitter le parti socialiste et devenir
un ministre d'ouverture de nicolas
sarkozy dans le gouvernement de françois
fillon en 2007 vous avez fait toute une
partie de votre carrière politique à
gauche pour finalement devenir un
ministre de droite
je pense ciblé que si le parti
socialiste à l'époque avait su écouter
des gens comme moi sur un certain nombre
d'idées de propositions
si on a vu simplement si on avait
simplement été respectée pour ce qu'ont
représenté dans ce qu'on pouvait porter
comme comme comme l'idée comme démarche
politique
je pense que je pense que j'y serais
resté mais avec des si vous savez et
d'ailleurs si le parti socialiste a été
comme ça aujourd'hui il serait peut-être
en meilleure forme
alors que justement on est de l'autre
côté j'avais mes responsabilités locales
dans lesquelles j'étais très engagé ça
m'avait amené à prendre des
responsabilités de président de
l'association des grandes villes
françaises et qui m'avait mis en
relation bain avec sarkozy qui était
mise l'intérieur etc
et franchement je ne pensais pas que ça
arriverait
je n'aspirais pas à sarran quand
harley dans des conversations privées je
me disais chaque fois pourvu que ça
n'arrive jamais
un jour je pense que je devais tellement
au bout de mon histoire au ps en plus
cette ouverture
je peux vous dire dans un premier temps
j'avais refusé avant la présidentielle
en disant non je suis engagé chez moi en
alsace en soutien de ségolène royal
quoi que je puisse en penser par
ailleurs
je la soutiendrai jusqu'au bout ce que
j'ai fait je l'accueille à mulhouse et
c'est ensuite
augment des législatives qui ont suivi
on m'a dit mais maintenant j'y non j'ai
des gens qui me sont proches qui vont
s'engager puisque moi-même à l'époque
j'étais sénateur
donc je vais les soutiens non je ne vous
suivrai pas et au lendemain des deux
élections présidentielle et législatives
il ya eu donc une démarche d'ouverture
qui s'est élargie puisqu'il avait déjà
eu kouchner et d'autre donc je me suis
sentie oui c'est vrai dans une démarche
politique un peu construite avec un
discours de sarkozy alors après ça s'est
retourné évidemment un
aujourd'hui ceux qui ne l'aiment pas le
juge sur les années sur les mois qui ont
suivi
mais au moment où il devenu président
80% des français même ceux qui n'avaient
par définition pas voté pour lui
penser qu'il allait incarner quelque
chose à une espèce de synthèse de
modernisation de la france dans même
s'il y avait eu des évidemment des
dératés quand ils étaient mises à
l'intérieur mais tout ça vous savez y
ait des moments comme ça de grâce pour
moi qui suis je me suis engagé à ce
moment là en tout cas vous vous doutez
bien que ce parcours a suscité beaucoup
d'interrogations bien en question avec
les internautes et religieux depuis le
temps j'ai l'habitude quoi mais
justement c'est tellement facile de
diaboliser les gens quoi c'est une bonne
question diaboliser du coup nous sommes
de raison qu'on m'a dit en face d'une
question que je vous pose un joli
pourquoi un internaute à dix meilleurs
du coup est ce qu'un jeune de gauche est
devenue et est condamné à devenir un
vieux de droite c'est une très bonne
question c'est quoi c'est la sagesse
avec le père avant droite c'est ce que
les non je dis pas ça
je pense que non il n'est pas condamné
on est condamné à rien on garde son
libre arbitre et un mouvement mais
souley
un jeune forcément quel que soit son
parcours politique
c'est normal c'est les lois de la vie
ils évoluent son regard change auraient
le regard que vous portez sur la société
sur la capacité de la transformer sur
votre idéal à 20 ans à 50 ans à 70 ans
il n'est pas le même mais ces évolutions
elles peuvent se faire à l'intérieur
d'une même famille et des gens qui sont
fidèles à la gauche pendant 50-60 ans il
ya des gens qui changent tout le temps
et il ya des gens qui ont toujours des
droites mais il tout le monde change
donc c'est trop facile de de faire une
analyse uniquement générationnel je
pense qu'il faut faire de la situation
politique actuelle de la france des
partis politiques de la crise qu'il
traverse
une analyse qui soit pas générationnel
mais qu'ils soient politiques
est ce que si j'avais 20 ans aujourd'hui
je serai dans les mouvements radicaux
que vous avez cités tout à l'heure
honnêtement sans doute mais non je ne le
pense pas parce que enfin l'enjeu
ok il ya eu 68 il y avait à peu près
tout le monde à toute la jeunesse s'est
senti à un moment donné concernés à part
quelques-uns qui ont été dans des
mouvements occident fachos etc mais ou
plus ou même une agglo dans les
mouvements gaulliste ou centristes mais
une grande majorité de la jeunesse s'est
senti concerné après par exemple
beaucoup sont allés au ps une fois
aujourd'hui sûr d'aller à la ligue
communiste révolutionnaire dans des
partis d'extrême gauche
moi j'ai après avoir hésité quelques
années après avoir été même abandonnée
proche du parti radical du cerveau
schreiber quitté espèce de parti
centriste le progressiste j'ai fini par
aller au parti socialiste parce qu'il me
paraissait à la fois dans le mouvement
social dans le mouvement de la société
et quand même sérieux s2000 si vous êtes
mon frère je vais vous dire un truc qui
va peut-être un peu énervé vos interne
mais j'ai pas le temps de tout regarder
comme je vous parle je regarde moi mais
j'ai toujours été assez entre guillemets
modéré quand même quoi raisonnable à
certains égards je me suis jamais senti
à l'aise dans les assemblées on se payer
de mots quoi
mais voilà je pense que j'aurais pas
faire bon révolutionnaire vous auriez
voilà vous auriez 18 ans aujourd'hui
vous n'auriez pas été à la manif hier
contre la violence policière
je sais pas j'ai pas dit ça j'étais dans
les manifs à strasbourg comme étudiant
j'étais dans des manifs de ce genre non
je ne dis prétoire d'accord d'accord
alors j'ai parce que j'ai quand même
jeter un coup d'oeil la claque quelques
secondes mais si ce n'est pas déjà fait
on me dit on me dit on me dit oui non
mais ambitieux jeu j'ai agi par omission
bien sûr que oui alors des mots de vente
physique est alors alors expliqué
maladie cancer bats attendez je suis et
moi on est ambitieux moi je considère
que pour quelqu'un qui est jeune avoir
une ambition c'est formidable c'est un
moteur y a rien de pire que de se
laisser ballotter par le vent les
opportunités avoir une ambition c'est
bien
être arriviste c'est à dire sa soif sur
les autres pour avancer
c'est mal d'accord j'ai toujours essayé
toujours quelques étés mais mes choix du
moment d'évolution d'étiquettes même
j'ai changé une fois dans ma vie de bord
pas deux mais j'ai toujours j'étais pas
que j'y suis toujours arriver une le
souci de ne pas me comporter comme un
n'arrive ici tu vous donne un exemple
en tout cas le chat était né dans la vie
difficile pardon non le chat est assez
d'accord avec ça j'ai été maire pendant
21 ans j'étais élu quatre fois déjà le
faire d'une ville très difficile dans
une ville facile c'était pas la rochelle
ce n'est pas neuilly c'était une
formidable par ailleurs mais j'y vis
toujours givi je suis à paris toutes les
semaines mais je vis à mulhouse
difficile et bien si vous avez
simplement un comportement arriviste
vous dépêcher de fuir un de vous hisser
une responsabilité pour aller vers une
autre
d'aucuns le fond moi quelques étaient
mes responsabilités par ailleurs alors à
l'époque la loi c'était le cumul la
règle c'était le cumul aujourd'hui c'est
mal
à l'époque c'était bien bon je porte pas
de jugement c'était une autre époque
mais j'ai toujours mis d'abord ma ville
c'était une fidélité
ce n'était pas de l'arriviste mais j'ai
toujours été ambitieux j'ai toujours
voulu donner le meilleur de moi même
j'ai toujours j'ai rarement refuser un
d'aller un peu plus loin un c'est à dire
de prendre des risques si vous voulez
quelque chose s'assume pleinement oui
pardon non non il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant une question qui vous est
posée macron n'est-il pas un arriviste
coûté sa nouvelle cette nouvelle
génération au match macro
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez c'est trop tôt pour
porter un jugement
je dis pas qu'il faut nommer macron
toute façon par définition il est de bon
ton de le détester et de le devenir
moi j'ai un jugement nuancé le lire je
n'ai pas soutenu
vous savez on fait un peu de
psychanalyse puisqu'on est sur moi en
fait
au début quand je les ai vus arriver
avec son idéal européen
son souci d'équilibré entre le social
l'économie que sa vision sur
l'intelligence c'est parce que j'ai été
j'ai voté pour lui aux deux tours et
j'ai été très admiratif puis enfin un
président etc et je suis mais pourquoi
tu l'a pas soutenu d'ailleurs d'un point
de vue ou populistes ça aurait pu être
malin en fait
bon il n'ya jamais une raison mais je
donne la raison principale est ailleurs
les personnes que je connais qui me
connaissent avec qui j'en ai parlé au
début c'est sûrement vrai ce que tu dis
c'est quoi alors eh ben
si vous voulez tout mais vicissitudes à
l'intérieur de la gauche
qu'on a rapidement évoqué tout à l'heure
on pas empêché de rester pendant 34 ans
de ma vie
34 ans j'ai 70 ans au parti socialiste
donc quand je les quitter pour entrer
dans le gouvernement de droite
c'était pour moi une rupture terrible y
compris jeu
certains de mes meilleurs amis se sont
éloignés enfin je pourrais vous parler
longtemps ma femme l'a pas très bien
vécu sur le moment et c'est bon on a
surmonté tout ça mais c'était pas
évident et bien une fois on peut changer
une fois c'était la fin d'un processus
mais jamais je ne serai une girouette et
donc l'idée de dire je vais maintenant à
nouveau faire un changement majeur pour
soutenir ce jeune candidat et c'est
alors que j'ai été sollicité alors que
je me suis posé la question gêne ne le
fait pas la voyez enfin pourrait pour
répondre à votre question sur sur
l'image de macron gênant mais j'en ai
d'autres parce que je ne le vis pas
comme un opportuniste après est ce que
on peut critiquer sa présidence mais je
pense que quand vous voyez son histoire
avant 40 ans il s'est comporté comme un
ambitieux il s'est comporté comme
quelqu'un qui a saisi toutes les
opportunités qu'il a pu saisir mais on
voit bien qu'il a une vision un on voit
bien qu'en arrivant à la présidence il a
l'ambition de faire les choses
pas simplement de rester là et d'occuper
le terrain donc je ne le qualifierais
pas l'arriviste il ya aussi des
questions beaucoup de questions qui qui
ont remonté des internautes qui disait
mais voilà un homme politique qui passe
de la gauche à la droite
est-ce que ça symbolise pas aussi un peu
ce qui nourrit le dégagisme ambiant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes le la
défiance envers le politique
il ya beaucoup qui m'ont dit bah oui
mais c'est un peu le symbole quoi c'est
un peu hors l'arrêtant droite gauche
tout ça c'est paris voyez ce que je veux
dire la réponse est oui
la réponse est oui vous le comprenez ça
j'ai dit la réponse est oui alors
pourquoi
ah ben voilà c'est très bonne question
en fait pourquoi quelqu'un c'est ainsi
que je me vis qui n'est pas une
girouette une girouette et respadd 34
ans dans un parti en prenant pendant la
moitié de ses 34 ans des coûts tout le
temps 1 ok donc quelqu'un qui fait ceux
qui franchissent le rubicon
c'est pas pour être ministre une fois
dans sa vie je l'avais déjà été très
jeunes me l'avait rappelé donc être
ministre pour être secrétaire d'état
quand on l'a déjà été à la limite c'est
pas le sujet donc c'est qu'à un moment
donné ce quelqu'un moi en l'occurrence
passionné par la politique considéré que
sa famille politique
plus
lavez plus
profondément déçus considérer que le
parti politique où il avait bâti toutes
ses espérances
ses ambitions sont idéales avait failli
et donc ce changement alimente le dga
nice dégagisme mais ce changement
il est le fait d'une d'un
affaiblissement d'un affadissement d'un
écroulement d'un éclatement des
structures politiques traditionnels qui
sont le point de départ de tout cela et
si j'ai une responsabilité
plus que d'avoir changé à un moment où
c'était vraiment plus d'accord
c'est de ne pas avoir su avec d'autres
et ça je me suis beaucoup lui sert que
le ps n'arrive pas là je n'ai pas vu le
talent un jour je me suis content et à
un congrès du ps car j'ai fait tous les
congrès pendant 7 34 ans en 2005 acheter
encore j'étais encore au ps plusieurs
fois j'avais calais avant de me compter
parce que j'entends ça veut dire quand
ça veut dire que comme je vous l'aï dit
au début de notre entretien
c'est ce qui était la force du ps c'est
qu'on se comptaient dans les congrès sur
des textes d'orientation de ce politique
de ce que devait être selon nous louper
un certain soutien c'est ça mais on
compter ses soutiens autour d'une ligne
politique et moi j'avais présenté au
vote des militants des adhérents ma
ligne politique de l'époque sociale
libérale comme je le dit et j'ai fait
moins de 1% à 0 7% mais j'étais j'ai
sillonné la france j'ai défendu mes
idées de cette ag pu le faire et donc je
me suis dit là ta place les plus là
c'est que tu allais et je me suis dit au
fond c'est que tu n'as pas eu le talent
c'est que tu n'as pas eu la force c'est
que tu n'as pas eu des qualités de faire
un jour je suis allé voir ce mieux un
jour challenge strauss kahn les unit
dominique on a les mêmes idées mais avec
le c'était quelques années avant la
suite de l'histoire ce n'est pas que je
vis ici toi plutôt que moi
porte ses idées donc je sais qu'elles
soutiennent on gagnera pas c'était un
congrès à dijon deux ans avant mais que
fera peut-être 20 30% et le coup d'après
tu gagnes c'est comme ça que ça se passe
le dit mais non les militants ne
comprendraient pas et puis tout ça je me
souviens très bien de ça donc je m'en
veux de ça d'accord je raccompagne
d'actualité au sénat maintenant
j'accompagne l'actualité au sénat je le
rappelle donc vous êtes sénateur du
haut-rhin ancien maire de mulhouse
aujourd'hui vous siéger au sein du
groupe union centriste
l'actualité du sénat évidemment c'est
l'actualité du déconfinement toujours
dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
david 19 il ya eu un vote important au
sénat ya quelques jours c'est
l'application stop qu'ovide
l'application mobile vous avez voté pour
oui alors que la majorité de votre
groupe a pas eu cette position là oui
mais la majorité du sénat comme la
majorité de l'assemblée toutes
sensibilités politiques confondues ont
fini par voter pour je n'ai d'ailleurs
installé ce matin j'allais vous demander
d'ailleurs vous la laisse pas tard oui
assez facilement écouter le secrétaire
d'état cdh rico que nous avons
d'ailleurs auditionné groupe centriste
au bout centristes on a des collègues
qui sont à l'impulsion des lois et qui
aurait été très en pointe sur la
question les risques de non respect la
vie privée la vie privée etc et ils ont
eu raison vous posez ces questions et le
ministre
dans un premier temps revu sa copie j'ai
vu c'est parce que c'est ce débat des
trois semaines avant la sortie de
confinement même un peu plus c'était pas
prêt il à retravailler sur rue il est
allé la commission nationale la cnil
informatique et libertés qui est très
indépendante et qui est très dur qui est
intransigeante
on a vu leur gré des changements cadeau
donc à partir du moment où stock co vide
à passer le cap de la cnil
moi je considère que tout ce qui peut
aider à prévenir
aujourd'hui bon là on est plutôt cool
mais peut-être dans six mois ou dans un
an le retour d'une pandémie car excusez
moi mais pour le moment l'état actuel de
ce qu'on sait on ne peut pas dire que ça
n'arrivera jamais et bien c'est un
dispositif qu'il ne faut pas refuser
c'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga ça va pas
sauver le monde c'est pas non plus le
diable
j'ai voté pour nous avons été une
majorité a voté pour et voilà mes
raisons il ya une question qui m'a été
posée par qui vous est posée du coup est
ce que les est ce que les parlementaires
ont suffisamment de bonnes connaissances
numérique pour voter sur des sujets
comme celui là c'est très technique le
numérique et je peut plaisanter un peu
allez-y
[Musique]
d'abord on a beaucoup appris ces
derniers temps
je peux vous dire on a progressé tous
pas seulement les parlementaires ensuite
on nous demande pas ce serait d'ailleurs
terriblement antidémocratique d'être
tous des ingénieurs des techniciens et
je vais vous donner un exemple il ya eu
et ne voyait aucune arrogance dans ce
que je vais dire un mais comme on
appelait temps on va à l'essentiel et
puis il faut aussi longtemps dans la vie
quand on est satisfait d'un travail
qu'on a fait il faut le dire moi alors
du coup je suis pas content moi je le
dis j'ai fait comme sénateur c'est peu
après que j'ai quitté le gouvernement
d'ailleurs les collaborateurs du sénat
était venu me voir nous avons cherche
quelqu'un c'était 2011 pour faire un
travail sur les enjeux de cybersécurité
l'aurait dit écoutez je n'y connais rien
si un tout petit peu j'avais des
secrétaires d'état à la défense
j'avais un peu abordé la question mais
je n'y connais rien et je ne suis pas
ingénieur mais c'est pas grave je suis
allé à fond sur ce sujet pendant presque
un an et je vous la fait courte on a
sorti un rapport qui était d'ailleurs
voté à l'unanimité de notre commission
sur la cyberdéfense cyberdéfense étant
le terme générique en france qui
recouvre les aspects défense et sécurité
l'aspect sécurité individuelle que nos
mythes ou quoi et nos propositions ont
été intégralement reprises dans le livre
blanc qui a suivi jeter dans
l'opposition à l'époque c'était l'époque
hollande ont été intégralement ou à 95%
reprise dans la loi de programmation et
ensuite on était notamment avec des gens
comme le drian à l'époque et quelques
ministres motivé intégralement mises en
oeuvre et ça a permis à la france était
très en retard de se remettre au niveau
de la plupart des grands pays européens
même si encore beaucoup à faire
et bien ce travail parlementaire a été
utile et je n'avais pas une compétence
particulière pour le faire mais j'ai
travaillé
j'estime que on a au moins la capacité
comprendre un certain nombre de choses
d'écouter ce qu'ils savent d'avoir le
recul nécessaire que n'ont pas toujours
les techniciens ou les spécialistes un
ingénieur peut commettre des erreurs
aussi
cette fin un peu mieux son sujet selon
ski mais attendez vous faut-il que tous
les parlementaires soient un jour des
ingénieurs le lendemain des médecins qui
avaient tous des avis différents
le surlendemain des juristes je suis
juriste de formation
nous sommes des parlementaires nous
travaillons dans des commissions
permanentes
nous travaillons beaucoup nous écoutons
beaucoup nous auditionnons beaucoup et
comme tout citoyen c'est ça la
démocratie à un moment donné eh bien on
se fait son idée et on fait des
propositions et qui parfois bain au fond
sont mises en oeuvre avec succès voilà
ma réponse
on va parler du en a parlé du territoire
maintenant vous l'avez rappelé à
plusieurs reprises vous êtes ancien
maire de mulhouse mulhouse dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler ces derniers
temps et pour cause très très très
frappé par l'épidémie a même eu un
hôpital militaire qui a été installé
pour décharger les hôpitaux
comment enfin est-ce que c'est pas un
peu un symbole malheureusement du
désengagement de l'état dans les
hôpitaux ce qui s'est passé à mulhouse
non non il ya un problème des hôpitaux
en france
mais mulhouse c'était un moment donné un
cluster parce qu'il ya une conjonction
d'éléments qui aurait pu arriver à
grenoble il ya eu ce rassemblement
évangélique il aurait pu arriver partout
les pauvres ils n'y étaient pour rien ce
qu'il ne savait pas vous avez homo il se
rassembler à 2500 pendant toute une
semaine à chanter à se tenir à un magnat
bon c
voilà ça aurait pu arriver ailleurs et
dans la même semaine
macron était en visite sur les enjeux de
communautarisme à mulhouse 1 à 200
mètres de ce rassemblement à l'oreille à
l'époque en faisant des selphy des bains
de foule et serra donc ok mais ça aurait
pu arriver n'importe où donc mulhouse
la caractéristique du blues c'est que
c'est tombé sur nous après il ya eu la
question des hôpitaux
moi je vais vous dire il
[Musique]
un des retours d'expérience de la crise
due qu'aux villes ça va être de revoir
complètement non seulement système
hospitalier mais le système de santé
français
ce que nous aurions dû faire depuis
longtemps comme maire les maires
président des conseils de surveillance
sont pas un très grand pouvoir mais ils
ont quand même une influence des
hôpitaux traditionnellement moi j'étais
impliqué pendant 30 ans dans un hôpital
1 c'est bon là on l'a beaucoup modernisé
on a des personnels extrêmement engagé
une de mes filles qui aide soignante en
avant pas que aux médecins etc et hugo
vite d'ailleurs
et bien c'est parce que il y avait ces
structures hospitalières
ce personnel médical et cette solidarité
qui sont mis en place et mulhouse a
bénéficié de la solidarité et l'hôpital
militaire mais aussi de tous les
hôpitaux alentour et même au delà mêmes
transfrontaliers en suisse et en
allemagne au luxembourg de manière à ce
que à aucun moment on ait été amené à
refuser des malades ou à ne pas les
soigner mais c'est vrai que ça me
ça montrait du doigt
les limites les insuffisances la crise
profonde du système hospitalier de santé
français et là j'ai vu le ministre avait
engagé ses états généraux c'est
indispensable
on aurait dû le faire plus tôt il faut
les réussir vincent dans le drame et le
mans mais le système n'a pas failli
et ça c'est dans la vie si vous voyez
que négative c'est comme tout à l'heure
sur la question du racisme
si on on peut être et certains
politiciens leçons ça je ne supporte pas
là tout va mal ah là là on est foutu ah
là là et c'est faux tout par
terre etc
on sait pas trop pourquoi faire après
non il faut toujours faire la part des
choses il ya ce qui va
et qu'il faut amplifier et qu'il faut
saluer et encourager
il ya ce qui va pas et qu'il faut
corriger
c'est comme ça que progresse une société
responsable qui n'a pas comme objectif
simplement l'effondrement la guerre
civile ou le chaos comme ça existe dans
bien des parties du monde puisque la
partie aussi des sénateurs je suis à la
commission que je préside à la fois la
délégation aux collectivités locales du
sénat je suis à la commission des
affaires étrangères et d'aller françois
c'est d'avoir constamment la vision
entre le local et le global et le global
1 c'est que le chaos ça peut devenir
très vite un dans un pays et à la fin
tout le monde est perdant donc
restons restons responsable mettant
modéré forcément mesurer non mais c'est
leur sport hautement le move ou 19 noms
ça quelqu'un dans chat thaler vincent
vous demandez n'y at il pas un peu trop
de technocrates à l'hôpital vous avez
travaillé sur le sujet vous avez
auditionné des élus locaux sur le
fonctionnement notamment des arn sa
fameuse agence régionale de santé on a
beaucoup déçu et voilà qu'ils sont un
petit jeu des critiques ensuite
génération de la crise et je partage la
vie de cette personne
en fait technocrates et à terme
péjoratif mais en fait il se trouve que
mulhouse c'est à 12km d'allemagne et on
est à une demi heure de voiture de balle
contre lui et bien ce pays
ces gens comme nous un niveau c'est des
pays on se ressemble on est cousin mais
ils ont un système de santé
décentralisée et où la part de
l'administration ce que vous appelez les
technocrates
il en faut en gros à une certaine époque
aujourd'hui je crois que ça a empiré en
allemagne elle était de 20% du personnel
hospitalier
il faut il faut des trésoriers il faut
des gestionnaires faut dire est faux
alors qu'en france cet été au moment
cette étude a été faite de plus de 30
c'est une énorme différence ouais mais
c'est beaucoup 1 % à 30 % si vous voulez
on a quand même un système qui
fonctionne fonctionne mal mais il
fonctionne donc pas dire non plus que 1
vous savez je dis souvent trop d'état
c'est pas bien il faut mieux d'état mais
quand je connais un peu les pays où il
ya plus d'états mobile connaît pas
beaucoup mieux est donc le système c'est
bien qu'alliés un complice d'un besoin
d'être administrés mais en france il est
sûr administrés donc il faut
rééquilibrer préserver une nécessaire
administration mais la faire évoluer par
les ars des agences régionales de la
santé
on a vu que c'était des gros machin qui
date d'une loi de 2009
n'était pas adapté à la crise
platement au revoir et ça c'est des
machins administratif de la santé et de
l'hôpital c'est complètement à revoir au
profit de du soin
vous l'avez dit vous-même trop de la
question des transfrontaliers très
importante
oui vous êtes à quelques kilos mais à
quelques kilomètres seulement en
allemagne on a reçu cédric perrin votre
votre voisin des territoires de voisins
et amis oui il ya quelques il ya
quelques semaines qui nous parlait des
difficultés ma frontière avec la suisse
des questions justement comment ça se
passe pour les travailleurs font france
à transfrontalier pardon entre la france
et l'allemagne dans le cadre de cette
poule de ce déconfinement pendant le
confinement
ils sont pu continuer à aller travailler
tous les jours de fermeture de la
frontière
il y a eu une fermeture de la frontière
et actuellement elle a du mal à ouvrir
pour tous les autres d'accord dire que
les travailleurs ont pu dans des
conditions dégradées parce qu'elle est
moins de points de passage mais assez
vite ils ont chacun vous pris des
habitudes avec des difficultés de trajet
plus long donc leur vie était plus dur
mais n'ont pas perdu leur job ça c'est
le positif parce que bas il ya quand
même des liens et également au niveau
des autorités locales passe comment des
états et également du monde économique
etc
donc ça c'est le positif et le négatif
c'est que on a du mal à des confiné
c'est à dire à réouvrir pour tout un
chacun
alors qu on est voisins qu'on fait les
courses de part et d'autre qu' on a donc
ça c'est un point que cédrika us il l'a
fait une raison de critiquer mais là
encore une fois tout n'a pas dix
fonctionné puisque les travailleurs
frontaliers n'ont jamais cessé de
travailler
donc du coup c'est hilal un lac
d'enghien pays d'ailleurs qui tous temps
il s'agit pas de la suède qui a fait un
peu n'importe quoi
mais la suisse et l'allemagne ont dit
régulièrement encore aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont plutôt un peu mieux débrouillé que
nous ils ont fait du confinement quand
il fallait le faire parfois plus
volontaire obligatoire parce que ils ont
un état d'esprit qui est plus
responsable plus disciplinés
et ils ont impacté leur économie mais
moins que nous vous le disiez tout à
l'heure vous est présenté comme un de
leurs rien très européen une question de
jules qui vous demandez ce que cette
crise ne va pas mettre à mal durablement
le principe de l'ouverture des
frontières européennes
elle va mettre à mal l'erreur que
schengen
qui était un enfer pavé de bonnes
intentions c'est à dire que on a à juste
titre voulu fluidifier les relations
à la fois des biens des personnes des
capitaux entre les pays partagez ce
destin commun et on s'est peu préoccupé
en tout cas pas assez des frontières
extérieures à cet ensemble est donc au
fond cette europe là
elle doit se refonder elle a commencé à
le faire quand vous voyez frontex par
exemple un c'est un truc qui qu'il faut
qui marche bien il faut juste le
développer et si on prend plus
généralement l'europe une crise comme
celle là après celle de 2008 peu où tu
es lampes et ce serait plutôt un drame à
mon avis ou permettre de la rebâtir
et d'aller sur de meilleures bases
l'initiative d'emmanuel macro et dans
gala merkel pour vous et ça va dans ce
sens là où sa condition qu' il n'y ait
pas un fossé qui se creuse entre les
pays vertueux du nord et les pays
cigales du sud dont la france fait
maintenant partie et que on arrive à
trouver les bons compromis que les
vertueux comprennent qu'ils seront pas
longtemps vertueux sinon plus leurs
partenaires clients du sud 1 et les
cigales du sud comprennent que l'état
s'est pas open bar le budget européen
s'est pas à fonds perdus une sorte de
c'est magique c'est magique
un nom il faut bien sûr pas mégoté sur
le le la sortie de crise
1 mais il faut un moment donné respecter
aussi quelques règles communes et c'est
ça l'europe
donc ça pour vous c'est un sursaut qui
va dans le bon sens le fait qu'angela
merkel et c'est un sursaut qui va dans
le bon sens d'accord d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron joue une partition assez
importante en ce moment justement sur le
sujet vous pensez que l'europe peut
mourir
malgré ce sursaut oui parce que si elle
donne sa reconstruction toute
construction humaine peut mourir
tous
humain peut mourir l'histoire l'histoire
de l'humanité le montre
toute construction
politique est un combat permanent
dès que vous vous reposer sur vos
lauriers l'europe a eu des succès c'est
la préparation de lendemains difficiles
donc
crise ça peut être l'occasion d'un mieux
shi qui disait le vieux la crise le 9 1
la crise c'est quand le vieux meurt
alors que le 9 n'a pas complètement
immergé stains entre eux deux cet
entre-deux peut être tragique
on a connu des moments dans les guerres
du xxème siècle etc ou plus récemment
certaines parties du monde qui continue
à souffrir terriblement et ça peut être
si l'occasion d'une renaissance
voilà c'est ce moment là qu'on vit en
même temps la notion de crise je suis
moi j'ai toujours absolument toujours
entendu dire qu'on est en crise les
crises et crise du temps où parler de
crise moi j'ai aussi depuis 93 c'est
pour ça que c'est trop liés bon je sais
pas si vous étiez nés en 93 moi j'avais
j'avais 23 ans je commence à faire de la
politique on parlait de crise mais
franchement c'était on garder
l'espérance que notre avenir serait
meilleur et quelques années plus tard
quand on commençait à avoir des enfants
que la vie de nos enfants seraient aussi
bonne ou pour ceux
c'est très intéressant que vous ou
meilleur est ce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien que c'est le contraire qui est en
train d'arriver
et donc ça vous voyez que les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui oui n'envisage pas le fait
que leur vie sera meilleure demain je
sais pas ce que ça va parler à leur
place mais le fait qu'il soit dénombre
le fait qu'ils se posent cette question
et que par moments il l'exprimé avec
désespoir ou désespérance et comment
dirais-je sans vraiment croire un avenir
possible
c'est quand même un signe fort comment
on fait pour voir comment on fait pour
avoir de l'espoir quand on avait en
temps dans un monde en récession dans un
monde en contraction dans un monde avec
le climat qui réchauffe
je vais je vais répondre puisque on
n'est pas loin de la fin de notre heure
avec les propos du début
on peut attendre que ça se passe
révolté sans lendemain
bien essayé de s'en sortir soit même et
de bâtir sa vie parce que pendant les
travaux les ventes continuent c'est à
dire pendant la crise
il ya quand même des opportunités des
choses qui vont bien mais on peut aussi
faire une chose
peu à mon avis être
thil s'est s'engagé c'est s'engager on
s'engage plus bas s'engage toujours mais
on a du mal à s'engager
on s'engage on s'engage plus dans le
collectif s'engager dans quelque chose
de collecte non s'engage encore bien sûr
mais c'est mais ça aussi ça doit
davantage s'engager
moi qui suis un homme politique il
faudrait que c'est pas nous qui allons
réinventer la politique
nous on peut tirer les enseignements de
nos erreurs et de nos réussites mais il
faut que la jeune génération
un réinvente une manière de s'engager en
politique de manière à pouvoir maîtriser
son destin son avenir et bâtir un monde
meilleur
donc le fait que les jeunes justement
n'aime plus trop les méthodes
traditionnelles d'engagement le bon
vieux parti à la papa louise en
réalisant réinvente mais il faut pas non
plus qu'ils se laissent éblouir par les
nouvelles technologies parle de
l'immédiateté 1 2 1 des dialogues qu'on
peut avoir ou chacun sa vérité
exclu l'autre condamne sans jugement et
c'est un passe à autre chose cinq
minutes après ou le lendemain
donc je caricature bien entendu mais
c'est comme je suis caricature et je
peux aussi caricature et c'est un
poulain pas tant que ça en fait ça sur
le ton de l'humour mais plus
sérieusement maintenant la politique
diers ou même d'avant-hier n'existera
plus la politique de demain est à
inventer
mais ça doit rester une forme
d'engagement et une forme d'engagement
avec une part de réflexion d'observation
des changes de camaraderie de combat de
vision comporte de prise de risque
peu importe les formes modernes que ça
prend il ya des fondamentaux
c'est ce que je viens de dire merci
beaucoup jean marie bockel d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci beaucoup
d'avoir passé une heure avec nous pour
nous raconter votre votre parcours et
votre vision merci à vous surtout
d'avoir suivi cette émission j'espère
qu'elle vous a plu vous pourrez la
retrouver en replay donc sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt vous pourrez
également l'écouter en podcast je vous
remercie à nouveau et je vous souhaite
une bonne fin de journée à la semaine
prochaine
au revoir
[Musique]